and so I never with school anything like
that no but like I said no brothers no
wife no kid no parent no parents no
parents no I never knew my father at all
I never saw him at all and I proved from
Cleveland
I pulled a clipboard but that's a good
reason why you see this bad well that's
bite time I flew back to Cleveland to
see him
excuse me my grandma's calling on
suppose the totally me said you're
already son in the town do you want to
see it
he wouldn't bother come see me just call
up who treats our eyes yeah you came
from Florida to Cleveland yeah he
wouldn't go mile he would get that baby
to bring me down there I said oh I'm not
going
so we talked on the phone and I told her
I said you'd all do drugs yeah yeah
that's a good thing yes yeah I know it
is
Johnson you do I got not overdo it at
wild sex and I got no girls pregnant I
said you know a pretty bill and I look
good he said well that's all good you
will come down see guys ain't no I'm not
and it is all good because my mother
taught me to do that that's gonna fall I
said it was a woman they taught me how
to be a bad you know I got some tissue I
got some baby wipes yeah actually it was
a woman who taught me how to be a man
but everything I learned by being the
man was from a woman that he would
conceive me so they had bought me a
round-trip ticket I got on the plane
four days later I flew back to
Jacksonville but idea
somebody I was so young I couldn't
recognize who he would he look like you
know but I've never seen somebody once
when I was very very young
no but I never saw him after that no mom
I saw somebody that you thought was your
dad well I saw a guy I remember the
black guys we was in a movie theater I
remember that I was very young you need
to work down I owned I think it was my
dad
you know but my mom died so early of
cancer so I was like 12 years old when
she died but for the schooling gold I uh
we traveled a lot because my grandmother
and my mother was fighting on who would
raise me and so she had to run away with
me and then by the time I got maybe
eight nine ten years old they felt my
mother had cancer wasn't able to take
him me so they put me in a foster home I
ran away from the foster home I miss
Clayton I took the garbage out one
morning she was a good lady give me a
minute here because I know sometimes I
get a little emotional when I think but
I'm good spirit but I'm saying some time
but I think about it because she was a
good woman
and what she knew I was gonna run but I
would cook the trash out then what did
he say uh so you say David come on back
and I looked at it and I took off
running I just walked down to try to run
I just wish she'd want coming back cuz I
was there one day and the first day I
was there this is another foster home
yeah the first day I was there I'm a
fighter right I never been a real coward
so the first day I was there one of my
brothers I met him in there
well foster brother he got to fight I
walked by the cone about 10 15 guys went
about three and four was on him and I
turned round I actually got should I say
uh he was white boy because it was a
foster hole right
I walked around I exhaust you I say uh
was wrong got your wedding why you stand
against the card all three these guys
that in front
you then when he looked at me he
wouldn't speak and I stepped up and I
said what's wrong if I said you could
talk to me and they didn't want to do is
terrified he said but what do you got to
do with this I said to my brother he's a
white boy your birthday we had a foster
home together that's my brother he said
well this man owes money but I say for
what he said because you got to pay to
live on this street I said I just moved
here I'm not paying you [ __ ] and I got
there and he said well we're Dracula
music College and I told myself no God
and when I went to fight these guys I
was doing pretty good with it three up
right the info on so I had a whole city
block he won fairly women and kids and
he hit me in the head with break this
was in Jacksonville Florida
and it was hitting me in the head with
bricks and sticks and when I got home
that evening shirt all up Johnson with
Rams people but I didn't I didn't take
it for he ran because he was young
and I realized he what the type of guy I
was you know everybody's not a fighter
some people are very brainy and smart
Johnson was very smart with books with
anything like that so he ran and when I
got home my shirt was trouble my eyes
with a swole not that real life
threatening but a little blood over here
and i guess i think i had to kill a
little three posted to the head with
some people i didn't hit with bricks
just [ __ ] and uh Sobers claims he's
eighty million would happily you want a
wrong that's another telling me as I was
saving Johnson who I said I loved it out
there playing doesn't worry about as
you're the manager oh you haven't please
don't bad we're taking the house they
put three folks into that but the next
morning when I woke up that's gonna live
like that alright so I took the garbage
guys he's gonna go run I ran I walked
away then she go I would come back and
they put my stuff on my face on milk
cartons and stuff come out have you seen
this kid and made it like I was from a
rich family or something they were
looking for me and I was at age of five
he put so you lost
do you lost your mom
about 12 years I never saw again I've
thought of that I mean I think I was
good once they put me in a foster home
they were running looking for me so much
I would raise why was they the only
would've talked about 12 to 13 cancer
and so did they put me in up and when
they caught me they put me in a like a
group home the well you know and I
called twitten and one was called
Trenton and one was called Marianna
it was boys of that crime but I had
never did no crime I was just you know
running from foster homes and stuff be
careful with eating you just know okay
when I was running from foster homes and
stuff so I never really did no crime but
they put me in there and uh I don't know
how to read in that kind of I do not
read that so I started walk you know
walk around looking at store saying oh
how much schooling did you get oh pretty
not hardly none uh I think I went to
Kenny God's about two months and maybe
elementary about a month
I never well how do we remember you
never saw high school you never saw even
great school
no no but you taught yourself to read
yeah I taught myself to read by walking
and looking in signs and stuff and just
standing there just wait like FedEx you
know then I would figure it out and I
would just figure it out I kept I kept
trying and smile at any beat and he's
being you know I kept picking it out and
I got missed over a lot I went to jail
about the thing I mean prison a lot
because I couldn't read contracts and
stuff like that like one time I stole
already oh I was just wanted to get
something to eat you know I was an
Oklahoman it was already on the car seat
I just reached and grabbed this a small
misdemeanor right first time I've ever
been in trouble and they sent me to
prison for three years for that and then
I need to tell you something awful
record though when you knocked the
camera
like it's kind of private and so I kept
going going to jail and I was learning
to read I was getting better but I kept
going to jail not because I was a hell
of a law breaker but because I didn't
have nobody to no lawyer no money no
family of nothing and I could tell from
the way that the things I did all that
something's going on in the world I knew
I had to dodge that knew that you were
messing me over it just wasn't I
couldn't do nothing about it I was so
young and I didn't understand you know a
lot of things back there in the course
so oh yeah it's not that's just what we
like meeting sometime you know you can't
be bitter about that long as you grow up
because you know I tell people never
gonna live in a problem-free world's
upset it's always gonna be a problem
to every solution there's a to every
problem there's a solution but to every
solution there's another problem than
caring you know so we have to learn to
live with that and then I got raped one
time I want to try to rape me one time
in Cleveland Ohio he took me in the
buddy's head and put a fork to my neck
and uh I was young and I jumped out the
window with my underwear on and ran down
the alleyway
I was about that's probably about 13 14
then somewhere but I was very I wasn't
even 15 at that time so I don't know I
was
he's a 14 at younger and uh I tried to
tell the police about it and they they
talked me out of the clean ride and say
well you sure you want to press charges
oldest guys go to court telling all that
stuff in the courtroom and you know your
majors only let it go you know I didn't
want you what I did cuz they y'all yeah
they they made me think that I would be
embarrassed in the courtroom but I'd
tell all this stuff and I never I never
reported it but then one time I was in
LA I was homeless in Hollywood and I
came one of the most beautiful girls I
had ever seen in my life my name was
Mike tail she was a white guy long blond
hair all the way down
their kneecaps Elise and she was
standing in front of one of the roughest
or the Hollywoods back then it was
roughing that real nasty back then full
of gangbangers and full of rough guys
like you know we had to be ruffles of
the ruffles like that cuz this was like
in the eighties early eighties and uh
did nobody care but anyway later long
story short I had a friend work for the
police department
my chair wouldn't tell me where she was
from but she's very beautiful and I
wondered so she likes me and I won she
when we stay together and like she
wanted to be with me right and I wanted
to brother I can't expand on who I'm
sleeping with you know I can't do that
tough out who this girl is no ID so I
gave my picture to a buddy of mine at
police station he came back with a
poster and she was facing this way and
that way with all these things in front
of her
that's all beautiful woman a criminal
we're always a she was it so on the
bottom of the posters they called this
number I called the numbing it was
apparent and he said I said you have a
daughter named Mitel he said yes we
looking for a Sheila he's very young and
she ran away from home I say was he's
out here in Los Angeles California
suburb sub-brands not as I said he's not
here in the suburb of Los Angeles
California called Hollywood he said yes
yes he said we want her home I say okay
I'm gonna put her on a bus and send her
back to y'all you be at the bus station
to pick up he said oh no you can't do
that you're jumping she'll jump off the
bus I'm saving sir what do you want me
to do he said we'll pay you bring her
back out here she had to go to Kenosha
Wisconsin what of a suburb right off I
mean of City right off the board of
Illinois it supposed to be the last
little city yeah a giant take her to
Kenosha Wisconsin and he said brie say
bring her back nothing I say you want me
you want me to leave Los Angeles right
now come all the way out to Chicago to
bring your dog home he's a UH
ain't gonna happen sir I just can't pull
up like that and just leave loss and
just like that he say well with $2,000
and make you do that they come again
easy I'll pay you two grand you break my
daughter oh I see okay
I guess I'm going on a trip just on the
greyhound and we rolled all the way
greyhounds he cried and didn't want to
go back once a message I can it's too
rough out there
you know I have no way of taking care of
you and you know it's two days
everybody's killing everybody this is
not the place for you right now
and so she's glad I got to Chicago bus
station I took this kinda guys you go to
Kenosha Wisconsin a medicine Chicago and
so when they got in Chicago appearance
they looked at me like
boy that's a rough look dude he grabbed
me I was dressed night
whatever geez on the back nice amount of
Penn steel toe booster can with the head
overlap Oh with the spillover and then
you know I'm wearing shorts when I come
on defendants man it is cold out there
but it was hot along the engine so when
shield fell off my veins sticking out of
my legs it you know I got a jacket a
hoodie on but I got a hoodie on with a
zip down there I'd have his neck of that
attack I had a hoodie on and I was
really bigger than you know I'm just
kind of cutting down my head a little
size did and so they looked at me like
orders do look rough you know so I
walked I walked up to when they saw my
tent Walker does and I say yes this is
your daughter
nobody's ever touched her and she's like
home and she cries he won't see me
crying there and that grew in that out
of Chicago bus station and I said damn
what a bust man I got to take a long bus
ride back night ain't no we're gonna get
you a motel for a couple of days and
we're gonna let you we gonna give you
2,000 others go get you an Amtrak I say
when you go how you gonna do all that
I'm not going to stay around with y'all
and I'm not going after your house then
we go round st. never been to before
with people I don't know you know he say
no
get your motel we just go we gonna make
sure you get the room and we're gonna
give you money and uh get enough money
eat our own and stuff like that we're
gonna give them money buy your ticket if
you not if you don't feel you know that
relax you know dinner but the people you
know boys I understand you know you know
he said I'm glad you brought my daughter
took y'all that so I can't I got a
little owner on the Amtrak the first
time they were rolling an Amtrak train
and I got a time train came back along
happily these big-ass windows and you
could drink on the Amtrak and you know
the amp they took us through Colorado
and what I did not know is that uh all
the time way up in the Colorado
mountains I never saw a snow white buck
but I saw a snow white bunk with a pink
nose and I say and I say how'd that
happen
he said we don't get my son up here cuz
they get too cold and the Bucs don't get
no uh don't get that my son say but snow
white and not having I think it's funny
no yeah he said a buck and so uh and on
that time and oh one thing I forgot to
another girl huh never hear from the
girl again no I never did hear from
again I never did it for my tail no more
will do good thing because I can tell
when I talk to her she's not ready for
this kind of like I don't know here ever
be my tent was very intelligent and very
smart but she like a a girl would being
a college or good job she's not street
smart and out here they would have
probably raped her gave my aid give him
pregnant anytime soon and whatever
Christian on a man would have been
messed up you know
but now one thing I forgot to tell you
when I was taking her back on the way
down me and my tail got on the right bus
cuz it was two Greyhound buses they got
to for the first one I had a bus laying
off the side of a cliff and killed
everybody on the bus
oh you're kidding no they ran funny one
of those we got on the second bus and
we'd have been on the first bus we would
have died cuz it was slowly the icing
rolled or something like that and one of
the Greyhound buses ran off the side of
the
thing some kind of ravine chai deceive
me but I ran off come kind of steep edge
and from what I heard from what they say
about the bus everybody on the bus died
just every bump that great that first
round got killed there so once I got
back to LA you know I got back in the
street all the time I was always
homeless with no family when I'm going
through this so I don't know how I got
into all these experiences but and I
lived in many different cultures I
losing I was homeless and New York was
very cold at I was homeless and creaming
that made my way to Seattle while I was
homeless that and you're entirely
self-taught yeah and so uh that's going
no school and uh yeah just a month you
know learning from from people you're
looking at they behaving the way they do
things and painters pay attention to
life and you know but no school and no
no no tutoring no teaching and they're
like how old are you
53 now I just had a birthday two weeks
ago three weeks ago
yeah and so on and so no little school
in the world
no tutoring no one and matter of fact as
I learned a lot of people out here say
how did you learn all that did you speak
you know he said I listen to the things
you say and a lot of the guys on the
street try to get me to teach them and I
say uh do you uh think I can teach you
anything he say yeah you I hear you talk
he say I say do you know I don't have
one day in school of myself I'm gonna
teach you he said we just teach they
were looking at me said we just teach to
us with you what you talking about right
there
we need accent you to give us no
education we just want to learn some of
the stuff you know I said okay I do the
best I can and then uh and so I did that
I thought would help God even the guys
right here now even a young doing they
hear me talk
there's someone be ready to beat me up
and this one big guy always look at me
and say I keep forgetting to beat that
little money saver you always hey man
you know you think we want to kick his
leg he's talking but we always right so
so you're you had 12 years with your mom
yeah how was your relationship with your
mom
me my mom we got along real good while
she were living but she was so sick all
the time with cancer you know that's
another reason I that Ghost glad to stay
here her I'd stay home and take care of
her because she was in the hospital for
a long time but for a while but maybe we
couldn't afford a hospital bill so now I
had to stay home and take care of her
your honor you know yeah and then until
they took me to put me in a foster home
and once they took me there I never got
to see again she died before I'd ever
see her again you know and and then and
when and once and I would the prison up
here in California for a while but what
happened the way I got it I found out
about her again I never met another
sisters or cousins right but had a
missing person report out on me my mom's
only child right and when I got our
prison here two cops into one of the
station's told me say you know you got a
missing person before I love you I said
I have no family to be missing he said
somebody out there looking for you and
they from Cleveland Ohio now I don't
know if you got family not in the days
of missing for somebody I did look at
you that's all right and he gave me a
number and I called a number and this
woman on the phone say I'm your aunt
Internet we look for you for years
my sister's only child you said we look
for you for years
and we couldn't find you I say where's
my father
yeah your mother died
but it did I thought she was barely
Cleveland to let me go to Georgia where
her father would let my grandfather for
the first time Odie's Bank about a week
and I said what cemetery my brother Brad
would go see the grade and they by the
way on the wood everybody put in the
goods every time it's bad the tree that
grows over Gregory in the body big two
three the grain that's hot is what you
do to your daughter
there's a lot that is what you do to
your sister you better wear D what
nobody see that that's all about the
grain and the way a sister and her
daughter won't see him oh well I never
went back and I could it was just all
like I didn't care so much about but
yeah she was always sick and she was a
good woman
it was all a fool excuse me
I've got a very big guy down so I need
being an only child a very small guy
like those schools a little buddy teach
me I had to learn the best way I could
that's not picking up old thing is it
and I told myself your mothers are great
and your grandmother go through so
you're not gonna grow up Ignis and
you're not gonna grow up not having the
life and you're gonna teach yourself and
you gonna do whatever you can and you
gonna work hard but you will not be a
loser you might be Pope but you're not
gonna be a loser and I follow on it this
is where Larry and of that man in life
I'm happy it's just some of the things
that I think about in the past that
makes me a little emotional but I've had
a good life and I'm proud of my life and
uh I never really was materialistic
anywhere never had a driver's license a
pole house I never had touched a woman
in 14 years I'm like a I'm disease-free
but I'm had no tattoos little peers is
and is that you know and I see you all
the time I've seen you hundreds of times
you're always happy yeah I'm always
happy always and Goodman yeah because uh
excuse me being in a bad mood a little
bit make it worse said it's not the word
I don't feel like it's the world but
you're honest yeah you're hard-working
right you're good guy you help out
people that need help yes I do
anytime I gave out you oboes I have a
pack of cigarettes what everybody I get
like the mayor of Skid Row yeah pretty
much me another guy you have a secretary
being held we are different type of
characters but you know same time you
know live a saying we help these young
people to but you know our dad person a
little different but other than that you
know we both say so that's it right
there for me right now
awesome I know you got things do anybody
got other people coming in so we gonna
we gonna cut it short to the world thank
you and uh whatever you see on this I
hope you enjoy it's only for your
entertainment it uh but your listen so
thank you all out there have a good life
all right
she goes great so that was a three-part
video I'm singing your to our talking
all the time
everything you shares always yeah